Layla tried to cancel on the dates I
told him I was sick and he goes you're
not sick how did you know she didn't
have conviction she's like oh well I'm
kind of sick I was like you're on the
phone with me no that's sick no I really
don't feel good he's like yeah you're
fine we're going on the date tomorrow
and I was like what I kind of
appreciated it nobody ever pushes back
on me what made you hesitant about that
I've had so many bad dates at this point
part of me thought that Alex might be
like a little bit of a sociopath when I
talked to him so I was like I don't know
like the way he's talking and everything
like he sounds a little sketchy so that
was honestly my inkling as well and then
turned out to be true so yeah there you
go